welcome to the second installment of
video game movie theme month otherwise
known as the the Gump dum this week
we're looking at a film from Mark
Neville Dean and Brian Taylor the same
guys that brought his crank - and that's
2009's gamer starring Gerard Butler
amber Valletta and Michael C Hall
straight up this film's main flaws that
it's too normal it's perfectly watchable
if you're looking for guns tits
explosions and a creepy fat man but it's
pretty formula that's not the end of the
world but it was a bit disappointing
watching this after watching the crank
movies were Neville Dean and Taylor
demonstrate a reckless disregard for
convention the funny thing is is that
the crank movies are actually better
video game movies than gamer which
despite the name has very little to do
with video games at all as a middle
ground film it doesn't have a long
laundry list of deep flaws but there's
one that I want to call attention to you
because it's a very subtle problem
that's ultimately the biggest weakness
gamer isn't worth watching more than
once and even then it's kind of boring
the reason for this is that it isn't a
very efficient script this is a subtle
problem because there really isn't any
one thing that you can point to and say
that right there that thing is useless
every scene in the film serves a proper
function and either establishes setting
builds character or moves the plot so in
a pure theory sense the script is fine
the flaw is that most scenes only do one
of those things we only learn one
important piece of information learn one
new thing about a character or the world
or see one event that moves the plot
forward for a movie that's edited like a
music video it's a surprisingly slow
moving story the plot is set up as a
mystery with a reasonably
well-constructed conspiracy but
information just comes out too slow
rather than snowballing towards a big
reveal the script drip feeds the
audience continuing to provide new
details until the very end
in fact we don't even learn the villains
end goal until the penultimate scene it
makes it really easy to follow the
conspiracy but it undermines the pacing
and honestly kills a lot of the drama
because important revelations just
aren't given enough time to sink in
let's run down the plot so we're all on
the same page in short John Tillman is a
fighter in a video game called Slayers
that uses death row convicts as the
avatars for players if a convict
survives 30 rounds they win their
freedom and at the start of the film
Tillman aka cable is on his 27th match
as the plot unfolds we learned the
castle the inventor of Slayers is up to
no good and plans to use the nano brain
technology to take over the world
Tilman knows this because he was one of
the first
subjects and castle used the tech to
make him murder the other test subject
which is why he was thrown in jail but
these are all kind of suppressed
memories that don't come out in detail
until Ludacris gives him a brain scan at
the end of the second act tilman manages
to break out of the game he rescues his
wife and daughter confronts castle they
fight Tillman wins people cheer they
shut down the mind-control network
Tillman and family drive off into the
unknown credits roll there's also
subplots involving a reporter trying to
get the scoop of her career a teenage
player controlling Tillman in the game
and a band of terrorists slash freedom
fighters called the human
with a Zed led by Ludacris most of them
died okay why would I say that has
little to do with video games well
because the video games in this context
are used only as a loose framing device
for a mystery story that's about control
only the outward trappings and facades
of video games are used the lingo and
the user interfaces but the actual
mechanics and broader social
implications of video games are missing
in the end the games depicted in gamer
are less video game and more reality TV
and sport first let's look at society
the other game castle invented where
players control real people to see how
this use of video games is little more
than a skin-deep reference it's
presented as a social game reminiscent
of Second Life
there was society the ultimate sim
environment where players don't control
virtual animated characters but actual
living breathing human beings they
walked them they talked them they juiced
him they rocked him the problem with
society is that it's actually a really
crappy game with tons of drawbacks and
almost no unique advantages first of all
players aren't controlling these games
with matrix-style brain plugs they're
not physically experiencing the events
they're playing the game on monitors
with voice commands and motion controls
meaning there's still that
depersonalized layer in the way of the
experience you're not actually living
life as a super hot woman for a time
you're just controlling an avatar that
looks like a superhot woman and
pretending to be them the lack of direct
stimulus is actually really important
because even with the other drawbacks
and limitations there would still be an
obvious appeal in the you could
experience drugs crazy sex or other
exotic experiences with little to no
personal inconvenience or repercussions
you'd be able to get blindingly drunk
than sober up the moment you
disconnected or experienced the rush of
jumping off something really high
without being the one to live with a
broken leg but that's not how it works
in society if you make your avatar get
drunk then all you've really done is
watch someone get drunk so let's talk
about the big downside there are
of limitations in society your avatar is
a real human being meaning if they get
injured sick or go home
they're unplayable you're also limited
to playing a human you can only make use
of the costumes that the actor has
available and you're limited to looking
like one of the actors also you're still
limited to the rules of reality you
can't run forever jump super high
breathe underwater fly a spaceship or
use magic plus you still have to deal
with scarcity if there's no room in the
bar you can't go in if all the cars are
taken you can't drive around if all the
arcade games are being played you have
to wait in line in contrast Second Life
allows you to play as a bipedal unicorn
a vampire a giant rabbit a robot or even
on airship the world uses simplified
rules that take out most of the
bothersome limitations of reality your
character doesn't become unplayable for
a year if you jump off a balcony and
break their legs they don't die if you
fail to feed them and they can teleport
from one side of the world to the other
he'll at the push of a button they can
fly there's still some obvious appeal in
society vicarious gratification
anonymous and idealized social
interaction reduce consequences for
abnormal or antisocial behavior you know
so on and so forth but none of these are
unique to society in fact the only thing
that's unique to society is the
knowledge that you're watching real
people the implication here is that the
main appeal of society isn't
role-playing and escapism its misery
tourism and custom pornography tons of
people would still sign up for that but
it's not a very good game slayers fares
a little better in comparison but still
falls victim to a lot of the same
problems the game wouldn't actually be
all that much fun because it's
incredibly inconvenient
you can only play during scheduled
events and if your Slayer dies you're
out of the match until the next match
the movie isn't explicit about the time
between matches but it seems to be at
least a day or two and during the time
between matches you have no apparent
opportunity to practice so it's going to
take forever to get to be any good at
the game there's a really odd moment in
the first scene with Simon the gamer in
control of Tilman we're a couple of
twins colum
and offer him money in exchange for a
turn playing his cable cable instant
transfer to the account of your choice
he was not for sale thank you this makes
almost no sense cable is a celebrity
okay but I don't get why they would want
to play his cable when the stakes are so
high because the game would be so hard
to get good at that just get cable
killed they wouldn't be semi famous
groupies they'd be the bimbos that got
an international celebrity killed
because they suck at the game and he is
an international celebrity the opening
credits go to great lengths to show just
how popular Slayers is and when Cable
wins his 28th match huge crowds of
people celebrate from Los Angeles to
Beijing considering the stakes involved
in being successful at a game that's
this popular in reality it would be
dominated by elite teams of players and
not apparently masses of unorganized
scrubs blindly charging at each other
since we're already going in that
direction it's worth pointing out that
the actual structure of Slayers is kind
of jacked up it's a team game sort of
it's hard to tell because it's
impossible to tell players apart from
each other they aren't color-coded into
teams or anything even on Simon's
user-interface but people occasionally
work together so it's not a complete
free-for-all alright I know that this is
starting to sound particularly nitpicky
but I think there's some good ideas in
here that could be salvaged for a better
movie basically if you want to include
video games as a central element of your
movies world then those games need to
behave right they need to feel right and
they need to work if they're not
believable then they break the
audience's immersion and diffuse tension
this is another part of why I said that
gamer isn't worth watching more than
once I know I go out of my way to
overthink this stuff but I can't be the
only person who watched this and kept
asking wait does this game have rules
with each successive viewing I realized
that they were basically playing
Calvinball
with the rules made up on the fly on a
story level since it's just mindless
bloodsport with made-up rules the whole
gamer avatar relationship ends up
feeling a bit superfluous and the themes
of control aren't developed enough to
make the
and poignant or insightful we live in
society we visit society I mean which
ones which one's more real really I mean
which one's really real no I mean
personally I kinda wish that dropped the
video aimed theme and just on a remake
of the Running Man final verdict it's
not a complete waste of time
Neville Dean and Taylor are great visual
storytellers the actors put in
entertaining performances but all in all
it's pretty forgettable next week
something well it's definitely memorable
postal sorry we're closed